Michelle is with us in New York City hi
Michelle how are you hi Dave good how
are you better than I deserve what's up
in your world right I'd like to know I
need to pay you off 117 thousand in debt
and I'd like to know what would be the
best way would be a reasonable time
frame based on my situation okay what is
your household income 110,000 excellent
and do you have any money saved in
anything I only have $3,000 and in fact
20,000 of the 117 is my emergency
savings so I'm calling it that oh so
you're not so you actually have 97
thousand dollars in debt making a
hundred thousand and then you need to
save an emergency fund in addition to
that yes exactly and with 97,000 is
really my mortgage oh okay farik I don't
have real checks okay excellent Wow okay
here's what here's what we teach folks
to do that is real debt but it's a
different kind of that we teach folks to
work up what we call the baby steps now
baby step one is to save $1,000 as your
starter emergency fund you have done
that okay that's three thousand yeah
right so you've got your thousand baby
step two is to be debt-free but your
home and you've done that well baby step
three is to have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses you have named that you said
it's 20,000 so that's that's your next
goal before you do anything else I want
you to save $20,000 on top of 16 on top
of that for that you've got so we get to
your 20 goal don't do anything else
until you do that that's your first goal
completely focus all of the money you
can squeeze out of your budget until you
hit that once you hit that then we take
you to what we call baby step four and
that's where you save 15% of your income
into retirement and if you've stopped
you're investing in order to get your
emergency fund in place that's when you
restart it and you're gonna be able to
do that very very quickly you'll save
20,000 years
very quickly you've got a low mortgage
payment you got a good income you're in
a high-cost living area but other than
that you're in a really good position so
you should really be able to attack that
and your state putting 15% aside and
then everything you can squeeze out of
your budget above 15% of your income
which in your case is about 17,000 years
saved invested for your retirement above
that above that we're just going start
throwing it at the mortgage now how fast
we're going to pay this mortgage off I
would say that mortgage is going to be
gone in five to seven years okay and I
have another question so I am
contributing 17% of my salary to a 403b
I would temporarily stop that until you
have your mortgage fund
completely temporarily just for a few
months I'm taking a very cheap package
no here's the thing if you have an
emergency if you have an emergency this
if you have a ten thousand dollar
emergency right now you don't any money
well these days I do have sixty thousand
inch box that I could cash it in well
that would be interesting information to
have okay yes cash out twenty thousand
dollars of that and put it in your
emergency fund today then don't stop
your 17 percent ballot back to 15 and
let's cash out the rest of the stock and
throw it at your mortgage now your
mortgage is going to be paid off from
today in about four and a half years
really you want me to cash in my stock
yeah we have a goal here paying off your
house and having an emergency fund and I
thought I need that for retirement and I
can just remember the 17% aside for
retirement and oh in addition to that I
do have a pension I work in a school and
it will be said yeah so you're going to
be set I think you're doing really good
you're doing better than you thought you
were doing if I could the more I talk to
you the more money shows up so by the
time we get off here you're gonna be a
millionaire it's good hey thanks for the
call hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey show
and did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right
kind of better than the Dave Ramsey
channel don't tell them I said that I'm
kidding I'm Danny so subscribe and
there's lots of videos about life and
money so while you're at it if you want
to check out a video then you can check
out how to do a monthly budget it's one
of the best videos out there
you